the number of stars in the universe is
quite uncountable their number in the
observable part of space may be upwards
of a septillion although the idea of
actually arriving at an exact value is
hardly feasible either now or indeed at
any point in the future
today's point in question is not stars
but larger structures they make up
as we know stellar systems together with
their rarefied gas and dark matter form
gravitationally bound structures called
galaxies
according to different estimates mankind
is currently able to observe several
hundred billion of them in different
stages of their revolution let's talk
about some of the most unusual ones
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
distances from the milky way to other
galaxies are by all accounts
mind-boggling as a rule it is anything
from millions to billions of light years
due to the universe's cosmological
expansion the distance between the earth
and any remote object in the universe is
constantly growing which makes the light
emanating from this object look redder
than it actually is
this phenomenon is known as a redshift
it is of great help in gauging distances
and velocities on the astronomical scale
alternatively some galaxy's spectrum is
blue shifted which means that they're
not on an escape trajectory from us but
on the contrary are moving to meet us
one of these unusual space objects is
the galaxy m86 in the virgo cluster
roughly 52 million light years away from
the sun it is moving towards the milky
way at a speed of around
244 kilometers per second which makes it
one of the fastest moving blue shifted
galaxies
by moving to high speed through the
scattered gas the virgo cluster is
filled with m86 is constantly shedding
its own interstellar matter
as a result of this process it leaves a
trail of long lines of warm ionized
hydrogen behind
m86 is connected with the almost
destroyed spiral galaxy ngc 4438 with
several of these filaments
these two galaxies are thought to have
collided at some point in the distant
past which was the smaller ones undoing
interestingly m86 is known to have
destroyed its other neighbors in the
past as well
several stellar streams have been
detected in its halo that are likely to
be the remains of smaller galaxies
absorbed earlier
an impressive number of globular
clusters in its structure is another
outstanding feature of m86
observations show that their number is
upwards of 3
and 800 which is around 25 times as many
as in the milky way
there is a theory that claims these
clusters to be the remains of dwarf
galaxies that m86 would have absorbed in
the past
if it really is the case
then it would have destroyed tens or
even hundreds of other galaxies
having said that m86 looks anything but
unique the galaxy eso 137-001
which we'll be looking at next has a
similar shape
but unlike m86 it appears more
outlandishly original
located
227 million light years away from the
sun it is as heavy as 5 to 14 billion
solar masses
as for its stars most of them are young
and bright blue giants iso
137-001 in its turn is part of abell
3627
a large galaxy cluster
moving to its center at an incredible
speed of almost 2 000 kilometers per
second the galaxy collides with
interstellar gas pressure inside the
cluster
as a result its own gas is blown out
leaving behind tails that stretch for up
to two hundred and sixty thousand light
years
incidentally the mass of interstellar
gas in those areas is two to four times
that of the gas inside the galaxy it is
hardly surprising that star bursts are a
common thing here
that is stars don't stop forming in
these enormous streams made up mostly of
hydrogen when seen from the side eso
137-001 appears like a giant jellyfish
floating through endless expanses of
space
unfortunately as the galaxies
continuously stripped of its
interstellar gas its life expectancy
diminishes too
with not much material left no new stars
can form here which greatly affects the
structure of the spiral arms and central
bulge of the galaxy
on the bright side scientists have a
chance of finding out more about dark
matter and its interaction with other
space objects by observing the behavior
of the gas streams left in the galaxy's
wake
speaking about the formation of new
stars there is a galaxy with a name that
speaks for itself
baby boom
around 4 000 stars are born here every
year which is about 400 times more than
in the milky way
straightforward calculations show that
on average an used star lights up in
this area of space every two hours
the baby boom galaxy lies around 12.2
billion light years away from the earth
this means that what we see when
observing it is what was happening just
one and a half billion years after the
hypothetical big bang
it was a time when the universe was
still in the process of forming its
structure what is taking place in the
galaxy now is drastically different from
what we expect to observe there in
theory based on what we know about star
formation
the reasons why stars are produced here
at such an astounding rate are not known
yet but it is beyond any doubt that baby
boom is able to provide us with a lot of
information about the early stages of
our universe's evolution
one of the few galaxies one can observe
through an amateur telescope is the
so-called sombrero galaxy official
designation m104
it lies 30 million light years away from
the sun and its diameter is roughly four
times smaller than that of the milky way
the sombrero galaxy's outstanding
feature is a massive ring of dust and
cold hydrogen enveloping it
observations show that it is here that
most young stars are born
in addition to the peculiar ring the
sombrero galaxy is also remarkable for
its elaborate inner makeup
observations with a spitzer space
telescope show that most stars in this
galaxy form a structure typical of
elliptical galaxies
the stars here are mostly rather old
yellow and red dwarves
the other stars here on the other hand
form spiral structures concealed with an
elliptical cloud it is thought that this
phenomenon is a result of two galaxies
collision with their stars subsequently
and almost inevitably mingling together
it is incredible that the galactic
structures survived a merge of that
scale with minimal damage are none the
worst for this tremendous collision and
can still be observed
another peculiar feature in the sombrero
galaxy is exceptionally powerful x-ray
radiation emanating from the center
it is assumed that the accretion disk of
a supermassive black hole may be its
source
the mass of the hole is estimated to be
over a billion solar masses which makes
this enormous object one of the most
massive black holes known to science
today
there are also several sources of
tremendously high frequency or terahertz
radiation detected within the galaxy
although today their nature is still a
mystery
our galactic parade today is concluded
with yet another object boasting an
elaborate inner structure
the erie m64 galaxy rather aptly dubbed
the black eye galaxy
the nickname comes from a dark band of
cosmic dust that partly conceals the
galaxy's center from the observer on the
earth due to this line of cosmic dust as
well as the exceptionally bright active
nucleus it is impossible to estimate the
black ice number of stars even roughly
what we do know is that it is
comparatively small and not so remote
its radius measures 25 000 light years
and it lies approximately 17 million
light years away from the milky way
the black eye galaxy is made up of two
well-defined parts
interestingly
the inner disc with a bulge rotate in
the direction opposite to that of the
outer ring
the most likely explanation for such a
bizarre makeup is that the galaxy formed
after two smaller ones collided and
merged in the distant past
admittedly it would take a combination
of a number of mutually independent
factors for such a fascinating and
well-defined structure to form
for example the progenitor galaxies
would have moved at specific velocities
and come together at a certain angle the
odds of a success would have been
minuscule
the universe shows a rich diversity of
hundreds of billions of galaxies
consisting of downright countless stars
of all makes and sizes from tiny dwarfs
to supergiants
among these there are countless amazing
and unique worlds
all together they constitute our
wonderful and mysterious universe
if you feel like learning more about it
subscribe to our channel if you still
haven't done so and look out for our new
and hopefully awesome videos let's keep
in touch
[Music]
[Music]
you